but the fans have been pushing for our
circuit panel for a minute now revenge
is not the Jedi way I am no Jedi you're
known for doing a lot of comic book
roles we've done I mean Marvel DC you've
got josie and the pussycats in city is
there is there a franchise you would
just love to tackle like how do we get
you in a Star Wars movie I know it's not
a comic book but yeah the fans have been
pushing for shook accounting for a
minute now yes yeah like someone said
the art and that I reposted it and the
Star Wars started following me and then
everybody started thinking it was a
whole thing and it's just literally been
this internet situation so Internet if
it happens because of you you would you
love that I would be awesome you're
incredible two lightsabers I mean if
you're gonna be a Jedi
might as well have - oh my god she's got
the Tatsu she's rockin the earrings this
is at your fan right yeah yeah I'm just
freaking out a little bit
oh good now people love your Marvel
character yeah I would love to see her
again do you think that that is possible
at all have you talked to Feige about
being in the movies at all I don't know
my boy Mikey like I don't know I mean it
would be amazing to you know kind of
keep playing with that character but I'm
just so grateful for the three years
that I got to be Claire temple and like
MacGyver nurse character which I love so
much and you know five different shows
like it was pretty remarkable I was
still so bummed I didn't get into the
Punisher but I think they were really
stretching for a fantastical show
stretching the imagination to imagine I
could be in all of those different
spaces but you know it was a really
powerful experience and incredible and
and got me into television for the first
time
since then I've now you know I've been
on Jane the Virgin for two seasons and I
just wrapped a briar patch
that's gonna be coming out in January
and it's such a different genre and
world you know if we were to go back to
that cartoon do it in film that'd be
something I understand a little more of
a television like I never knew what was
gonna happen they asked the time when we
were shooting characters didn't know
they were coming back because it was
always so hush-hush right and it's just
such a different thing to kind of be in
a project and really kind of go along
the journey with this character and it
was just an incredible journey grateful
and kind of mind blown that was your
first foray into television yeah I mean
accepting that I did I was in and one of
those like side episodes of the Sesame
Street you know they would have those
like little interlude short films or
it'd be like and now ours was on a
garden a community garden with like
turtles and kids picking fruit and my my
neighbor used to date a camera guy and
there she was she taught at this school
and I was like okay we're bringing
children's liberation we'll pay you
twenty dollars to watch the kids while
we're filming them and then I'm like
eleven years old and lanky I do some
narrating and I'm in it and I get
discovered from it everyone's Michael I
guess they still screen it yeah I read
like I get recognized and like I
remember just it was one of the coolest
things ever to be like Sesame Street
I've actually still never been to Sesame
Street I want to meet all of the Muppets
they'll be so amazing and but but I'm
still part of a little Sesame Street
world so that's my first little TV
she's part of so many universes you guys
try man I mean you're only here for
however long you're here might as well
yeah in every universe and dimension he
possibly
[Music]